2 x 2 cela fait cela fait pas grand
chose
je continue tant pis 2 x 3 2 x 3 ça fait
déjà ça fait un peu plus ouais ouais
deux fois 4 al assad deux fois 4 onces à
sable en fer entre les six et encore les
87 bon je vais vérifier avec ma règle à
calcul oui ma règle à calcul pour ça
fait rien je je je pose 8 h je retiens
12 cela me donne cela me donne l'âge du
capitaine
or alors qu'est ce que çà et
là ça m'a l'air très sérieuse que tu
fais là tu as des devoirs à faire pour
demain matin non non pas du tout je
prépare mes coups mois pour enseigner à
l'école de l'île aux enfants comme peut
le voir sur ce tableau je vais enseigner
le calcul la géométrie et la pifométrie
la lapi faux mais quoi la pifométrie
qu'est ce que c'est je viens le sud à
très forte en mathématiques mais j'ai
jamais entendu parler de la de la
pifométrie non c'est normal c'est une
science tout à fait nouvelle dont je
suis le génial inventeur bon mais je
t'expliquerai ça plus tard pas t'asseoir
tu seras ma première élève
alors je pose huit genres à majorque ya
12 j obtiens sortient l'âge du capitaine
qui a dit ça c'est moi qui me retient
bien puisque secteur tels propos que
vous arriviez en retard est déjà assez
grave que vous soyez sans mode excuses
n'étant plus à vous soucier la
perturbation ça devient intolérable
julie qu'est ce qui arriva casimir il a
l'air de très mauvaise humeur
françois je ne supporte pas que l'on
touche à pendant les cours alors qu'on
est bons contrats y auront bataillé et
allez vous asseoir oui monsieur six ans
on commence
je prends ma craint il va passer les
virages et je trace
en rond on ne dit pas rond mais un
cercle qui a dit ça c'est moi monsieur
on ne dit pas un héros mais un cercle et
là françois fortin journée assez moi
c'est toujours pareil on ne dit pas un
mot ni un cercle et puis d'abord c'est
un carré sortais je vous avait pourtant
prévenu
comment s'appelle cette aux figures
géométriques un réglage se croit aucun
dieu il me semble que c'est un quart et
un jour moi pour tout terrain
très bien j'aime ça vous aurez 0 ah ça
c'est haro par exemple enfin je veux
dire à serques
julie sortait pour bakhouch veut bien
casimir mais tu n'auras plus d'élèves et
et tu ne pourras pas savoir si taux
courts est au point non mais c'est vrai
je n'ai pas pensé il forme alors un
citoyen elle ne veut pas qu'ee pas nous
appelons françois et les enfants ils
vont aider françois les enfants venez
voir qui était le venez les enfants nous
allons essayer d'aider casimir a trouvé
le nom de certaines formes géométriques
très bonne idée regarde casimir
voilà
qu'est-ce que je reconnais moi c'est une
poule à non casimir très bien c'est une
sphère
alors quand je joue à la pétanque ou
deux jours on se fera
si tu veux qassimi rustu à peu près
compris enfin de toute façon la
géométrie à à côté de la pifométrie
c'est vraiment très facile très facile
la vie sous les truies questions
sexuelles oui c'est après casimir une
science très nouvelles dont il est le
génial inventeur
royal en est bien casimir vu tes
connaissances en géométrie d'une
permettra d'être un petit peu méfiants
quant à cette science que tu réinventer
mon pauvre françois tu fais partie de
ces gens qui pensent que la terre est
encore place alors que tout le monde ça
calais boulic sérique enfin la terre est
bien composée de deux emmy seront deux
hémisphères kymera l'on ne vous
chamailler pas françois laisse casimir
expliquer sa fameuse pifométrie enfin
jolie comment veux tu que je travaille
dans une fête atmos bouches de métro
tu veut sans doute dire une atmosphère
défiance françois sois gentil casimir
nous tu écoutes on allait alors la
pifométrie il est une science qui permet
de deviner des figures et des volumes
géométriques les yeux fermés
parfaitement je vais vous faire une
démonstration
kashiwa les yeux avec cote
viala casimir là tu ne vas pas je ne
vois rien parfait
maintenant prenez ce plateau
je commence la démonstration
bien ceci est un cylindre de chez bras
ceci est un rectangle de police et
leur étendue pont l'évêque ne pas
confondre avec le carré de l'est
attention ceci est un cercle de
camembert
ça c'est une magnifique bull dans
langues
et pour terminer un priant je devrais
voilà
quelques limites